so when the shootings happened over the
weekend we had the shooting in Dayton
Ohio and the shooting in El Paso Texas I
knew that this was going to be the
primary story for the entire week of
course we would be talking about the
shootings themselves we'd be talking
about the reactions of politicians to
the shootings we'd be talking about gun
safety regulations and all sorts of
related topics and I knew that none of
them were going to be monetized by
YouTube and this is not because YouTube
is targeting me or YouTube is targeting
the left or the right or whatever it's
simply because YouTube has made it very
very clear that to be what is called
brand safe this is literally the term
that they use you cannot talk about many
real adult serious bad things that
happen in the world you can talk about
it but those videos will be demonetised
so I was texting with other hosts over
the weekend and we were all saying we're
working for tips this week and this is
really serious stuff and I want to be
very clear with you these shootings and
our reactions and the reactions from our
elected officials this stuff has to be
covered and everybody that I spoke to
knew this is what we have to cover this
week even though it's going to
significantly negatively affect the
revenue that our program and our staff
and our studio rent and all of that
stuff relies on I could skip it all and
I could just spend the week covering
Trump's tweets and sports and you know
Maradona surgery in Argentina you
probably didn't hear about that one but
I've been following it and make a lot
more money on that but I'm doing a
disservice to you if I do that I
couldn't live with myself if I did that
but this is how monetization policies
shape the narrative because some people
will shy away from certain topics or not
cover them as fully as they should so an
intermediate way would be for me to do a
story about the shootings and then to
just forget about it for the rest of the
week and not tell you but as I did
earlier today as and is demonetized
that Fox News is parroting talking
points literally from the shooters
manifesto or talking about Donald
Trump's reactions to the shooting or
talking about Republican elected
officials blaming video games I could
choose not to cover it fully but that
would be the wrong
and so what happened is that on Monday
we had three videos related to the
shootings and all three videos were
demonetized
yesterday there was more work to do
there was more follow-up to do and
literally half of the videos we
published yesterday three of the six as
I'm showing on screen right now were
demonetized some of them got a ton of
views on which we made no money it's a
video here and a video there but when
you look at the views because these
videos did well which is important
because that means that people actually
care about this stuff
this week just from Monday and Tuesday
we had 350,000 views on these few Clips
demonetised completely so there are a
few things at play here first
it's the advertisers that drive this
it's not it's easy to blame YouTube and
of course YouTube is complicit in the
system it's not YouTube's fault per se
advertisers impose restrictions on
YouTube particularly since the panic of
ad pocalypse 2017 and YouTube wants to
placate them because YouTube is a
for-profit company so they say anything
remotely controversial related to crime
or violence or terrorism we will not run
ads on we will cater to you advertisers
is what YouTube effectively says not the
creators of course and in a way not to
the audience either because in some way
shape or form not everybody can do what
we do which is to say screw the
monetization I'm going to cover what's
important there are creators that either
choose to or are sort of forced into for
financial reasons
staying away from topics that they know
are going to be d monetized and in a way
it's so childish it's quite similar to
censorship in television with regard to
swear words and sexual situations in
other countries like my home country of
Argentina this is like no big deal you
know swearing on TV is not really a big
deal in many countries it's much more
common that when you're watching serious
news reports about bad things that
happen even what is shown is far less
sanitized and more graphic we can talk
about the impact on children or whatever
else that's a perfectly legitimate
conversation but in the United States
adults in many cases are not just
treated like adults when it comes to
media restrictions so that's number one
secondly this goes to the bigger problem
as I've been saying of the connection
between monetization of content and the
desires of advertisers that is
systemically a connection that is
problematic and so that's why you know I
really really really appreciate the
people that understand the sort of
urgency and destructive nature of that
status quo and have stepped up in the
last couple of months and funded us
directly as this problem has gotten
bigger and bigger on YouTube we had a
record record all-time record new
membership month in June awesome July
fell slightly short of that but July
became our second best month ever for
new supporters August is off to a good
enough start that maybe it'll come in
sort of around July right around second
best and the amazing thing is people
seem to be getting it and it could not
be happening at a more important time
membership culture supporting what you
believe in this is the path forward
there are easy ways to do it with our
show but you don't have to do it with
our show do it with whatever show is
important to you okay
membership this takes a minute david
pakman.com slash membership coupon codes
are available this is 20/20 saves you
40% I'll even give you a crazier coupon
code this one I usually don't mention
except in very specific situations the
coupon code half 19h AL f19 will save
you 50% off of the membership of your
choice if you want something simpler you
want not as big of a commitment maybe
not that membership is a big commitment
patreon patreon.com slash david pakman
show throw us a dollar a month it really
does make a difference and of course
please make sure that you are subscribed
to our youtube channel a lot of people
getting unsubscribed by a quote glitch
please subscribe to the youtube channel
at youtube.com slash the David Pakman
show
like comment and share this video if
you're watching on YouTube and support
us on the newest platform twitch I have
done
I guess it's for live streams on Twitch
now the engagement is great we have a
really great direct connection to the
audience there and I hope you'll join me
in the future on twitch at twitch.tv
slash David Pakman